I've got a really sick video to show you today.
Remember when Donald Trump briefly had that
interim attorney general, Matthew Whitaker?
He's the guy that had no business being attorney
general whatsoever, no credentials that would
justify being attorney general.
But after Jeff Sessions got pushed out by
Trump, but before William Barr was ultimately
put in place by Donald Trump, there was this
guy, Matthew Whitaker, who was the interim
A.G. Matthew Whitaker went on the super scandalously
sickening and scummy scam of a show, a judge,
Jeanine, on Fox News.
And he claimed that stay at home orders are
equivalent to martial law.
Now, we'll talk about martial law in a moment.
Here's Matthew Whitaker.
And here he is telling it to Judge Jeanine,
who seems just riveted by this.
Is this well-placed to make sure that our
our First Amendment and all constitutional
rights are infringed unnecessarily?
The Supreme Court said that any infringement
on those fundamental right has been narrowly
tailored.
And so lockdown orders or keeping people in
their houses under, you know, what would equate
to martial law is just not allowed.
It's not going to be tolerated by the Department
of Justice.
So I think you will get certain states that
are a little more restrictive.
I think the Department of Justice is painted
Kenai to right now lockdown orders are equivalent
to martial law.
So this is as good an opportunity as any to
talk about marshal law a little bit.
What is martial law?
Martial law is when the United States or parts
of it are placed under military control, often
with the suspension of the normal judicial
system, which is why habeas corpus is an important
aspect of this.
So the president can enact martial law federally.
Governors can enact state martial law.
One of the things that comes with martial
law is that habeas corpus can be suspended.
Habeas corpus is you have a right to a hearing,
unlawful imprisonment.
It is supervised by law enforcement.
And rather, the judiciary continues to supervise
the actions of law enforcement.
You can't just be indefinitely held without
being told what the charges are against
you.
And given relatively speedy access to due
process during martial law, the normal process,
due process could be suspended, meaning someone
could just be held indefinitely without charging
them, including by the military, which often
takes or can take a law enforcement role under
martial law.
So just deploying troops domestically is not
even necessarily martial law.
If the civil courts keep functioning, et cetera,
it still is not really martial law.
But martial law can include courts stop functioning,
civil courts stop functioning.
The military starts playing a judiciary role.
The military starts playing a law enforcement
role, et cetera.
Now, there are examples of when martial law
has been enacted.
You could look at New Orleans in the War of
1812.
You could look at after the Chicago fire of
1971.
While the fire was being extinguished, martial
law was put in place and then it was
lifted within a few days.
The San Francisco earthquake of 1986, martial
law was used to start confiscating dynamite.
To then destroy buildings that were in the
path of the fire, to try to prevent the fire
from spreading uncontrollably lifted within
a few days.
So, again, Matthew Whitaker says that stay
at home orders, he calls them lockdowns are
equivalent to martial law.
First of all, the lockdown is not being enforced
by force.
Grocery stores or open hardware stores are
open.
Every delivery service, Amazon, c_v_s_, Target,
they're all delivering tens of millions or
hundreds of millions of items all around the
country.
You can go for a walk.
You can go to the hospital.
It's just that, you know, there are some businesses
that are closed.
People are advised to stay home and maintain
social distance.
So for someone who was attorney general, to
suggest that the
lockdowns are even remotely like martial law
is dangerous because we know that there is
a large population out there.
The gun toting trumps types who are waiting
for martial law to go out and do really horrible
things if they believe that martial law has
been enacted by their governor.
That's the important thing.
At the same time, they seem very willing to
turn over control of the judiciary up to an
including a federal marshal lobbying enacted
by their lord and savior, Donald Trump, with
not much of a realization that during martial
law, oftentimes weapons are confiscated, which
they claim the government would only do over
there cold that hands or something like that
is the way the phrase goes.
So there's been only one entity, by the way,
that has lobbied for the suspension of habeas
corpus during all of this.
And it's Trump's Justice Department.
I reported to you a few weeks ago.
Trump's.
Justice Department asked because of corona
virus.
We want to be able to just hold people indefinitely
without due process because the courts are
all stopped up there, reduced capacity courts.
At this point in time.
So the one body here that has taken any action
that would even be associated with martial
law is the federal government.
It's Trump's administration asking for the
effective suspension of habeas corpus.
Whitaker is acting like we have going on here
what China had, where people's doors were
barred, shut with pieces of metal that were
welded together.
We can go out.
We are asked not to do so if it's not necessary.
Were asked to cover up with masks.
Stores have policies.
Some here in Massachusetts that say you can
only come into this store with a mask, stay
six feet away from
people.
Many coffee shops are even open, but for takeout
only restaurants are open.
Takeout only if this is martial law.
It seems martial law is just a lot more boring
than anything else.
But it is not the dystopian nightmare that
Matthew Whitaker seems to be claiming that
it is dangerous to spread the disinformation.